Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, listen, this this really bums
me out. I have been accurately telling you fine
folks in my audience, you can subscribe for free
to my YouTube channel. It's just it's YouTube.
You just subscribe. That just means you get our
videos. It's free. It's completely free. You can
subscribe for free to our podcast. It's on iTunes,
Spotify, Pandora, Stitcher. It's everywhere. It's
free. Okay. And. Every once in a while I get a
voicemail like this and it really bums me how.
Speaker 2: Hello. I'm Craig. On your side. You
say I'm on your podcast, I can subscribe for free
and there's nowhere to subscribe for free. What
kind of scam are you going? Yeah.
Speaker 1: There is no scam.
95% of the content we do on every platform is
free to everyone. We have a YouTube channel,
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. It's
YouTube, guys. It's free. You can subscribe free.
We have a podcast, an hour show every single
weekday. It's free. You go to our website,
you go to iTunes, you go whatever is
your favorite podcasting app? It's free.
What we charged for our website memberships, which
come with a commercial free version of the show.
They come with access to the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And they come with other perks. But
it's free to subscribe on YouTube. It's free
to subscribe to the podcast. There's no scam
here. There is no scam here. Let's all relax.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Joe
Biden is going after so-called junk fees. I
will tell you what these are. Texas is going
permit lists on guns. That'll go well. Right.
And three men have been convicted on all counts
for the plot to kidnap Michigan Democratic
Governor Gretchen Whitmer. Remember that story?
They have all been convicted on all counts. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign
up with peace and love. Join Pacman Dotcom. This
isn't free. Okay, this part's not free. You
can use the coupon code. Big voting 22 to get
a discount. But if you want to request a free
membership, we have some to give away. You can
request a free membership at David Pakman dot com
slash free membership. We'll see you on the show.